Hi everyone, welcome to today's Quartz Swiggin Hour on the topic of Burp Suite Enterprise
Edition. So we have a mixture of users on the call today, some of whom may have seen
the product a long time ago, some more recently, and some who may never have seen the product
before. But just before we get going, we'll just do a little bit of housekeeping. So I'm
Sophie Stevenson. I'm part of the Enterprise Advocate team here at Ports Swiggin. I work
with our trialists and customers to ensure they get the required support to evaluate or
procure Burp Suite Enterprise Edition. Alex?
Yeah, hi folks. So Alex, I work with the technical support team. So we help our customers with
the day-to-day support for both professional and enterprise. And today I'll be running us
through the demo.
We also have Adam, James, Maya and Hannah in the background today, managing the Q&A facilities
capability in the Zoom toolbar. If you want to ask any questions, please use the Zoom toolbar
during this session. We will try and respond to them all as quickly as we can, but we'll
also be picking out some questions at the end during the Q&A. Don't worry if we don't manage
to answer all your questions during the session, as we will be following up via email with the
answers. Just to let you all know, this session is also being recorded and it'll be available
on the Ports Swigger YouTube channel if you want to watch anything back or if you want to
send the link to any members of your team. And finally, the next session will be on the
10th of August. So if you do have any colleagues that would benefit from attending, please let
us know and we can extend the invite.
So just as a quick recap of the agenda, we'll be discussing the different versions of Burp
Suite. So that's both professional and enterprise. We'll cover the new features and enhancements
within Burp Suite Enterprise Edition. And following that, we'll touch on our licensing model, which
will lead us nicely into the product overview, which will feature new deployment methods, how to
get scanning quickly, integrations with CICD pipelines and issue tracking tools, and then
a sneak peek into our 2022 roadmap and round the webinar off, as I mentioned with a Q&A session.
So don't worry if you don't get a chance to make notes in all of this. As I said, the recording
will be available on the Ports Swigger YouTube channel and emailed out to you.
So our Burp Suite products. So many of you will be familiar with and likely use Burp Suite
Professional, which is our manual penetration testing toolkit with features such as proxy,
intruder and repeater. Burp Suite Enterprise and Professional both use the infamous Burp
Scanner. So Burp Suite Enterprise uses a scanner to carry out automated web vulnerability testing.
And these scans can be triggered by the inbuilt scheduler or via integration with the CICD pipeline,
something that Alex will demonstrate later in the session. The main reason we wanted to highlight this
is that it's often thought that Pro and Enterprise are a tiered product set, but in fact, they are designed
to be used to complement each other. Burp Suite Enterprise to provide the automated scanning and
faster feedback earlier in the software development lifecycle and then Professional for the more targeted
manual testing. In fact, the majority of our Burp Suite Enterprise Edition customers use Professional as well.
If you do need any further clarification, then please let the team know in the Q&A box here on Zoom.
So for those of you on the call who may not have seen the product for a few years, it's worth a quick
recap on what's new. I'm not going to cover all the items and it's by no means an exhaustive list,
but just to mention a few things. We have enhanced reporting on scan results against specific compliance
frameworks. So that's including PCI DSS and the OWASP top 10. You can now deploy Enterprise Edition
to your existing Kubernetes cluster much more easily using a Helm chart. And Alex will give you a bit more
detail on this shortly. And for those of you that are Pro users, you should be familiar with our BAP store.
So the new 2021.8 release added support for Burp extensions in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
But it's just worth noting that not all extensions are available, that are available in Pro are
available in Enterprise. And that's because the Enterprise extensions have to be written in Java.
And there's not that same ability to change the UI as there is in Pro.
So we've also added support for bulk actions in the UI, allowing you to add sites, move and delete sites
and folders, launch quick scans, or cancel and delete scans, all in bulk, whereas previously this was done
per action. And finally, we have made huge improvements to Burp Scanner in terms of its ability to scan
single page applications that are now synonymous with modern web architecture.
So, how is Burp Suite Enterprise Edition licensed?
So it's licensed on concurrent scans. We don't limit your number of applications, domains, URLs, users or anything else,
only on concurrent scans. And unlike most automated web vulnerability scanners, Enterprise Edition scans can be
assigned and reassigned across any apps, any applications, websites or URLs.
So, we often get asked, how many concurrent scans do I need? And the answer is, it all depends on the size of your
organisation and how secure you aim to be. So, obviously, companies with large web portfolios that need
to scan frequently will need more scanning resources than small companies who are just starting out with
automated scanning. So, just to look at an example, if you have 500 applications, you're probably not scanning
them all day every day. More realistically, you might be hitting 50 apps a day with a combination of
scheduled scans and scans triggered by your CI CD pipeline. So, assuming your scan times fit into a
working day, you only need to license 50 concurrent scans. So, if you kicked off more scans than you had
available, they would just be queued until they're free.
So, if you're interested in the same way. In terms of pricing, a Burp Suite Enterprise Edition
license with one concurrent scan, which is the minimum, would be $4,999. And each additional
concurrent scan would be $499. So, just as an example, a Burp Suite Enterprise Edition license with 50
concurrent scans would cost you $29,450 USD. And this is based off a 12-month subscription. However,
we do offer multi-year subscriptions for up to 10 years as well.
And then, architecture and deployment, I'm going to hand you over to Alex, and he's going to take
you through the next bit.
Alex O' Okay, folks. So, we'll just quickly cover off the architecture behind Enterprise and look at the
two deployment options, and then we'll jump into the demo and take a look at the product.
So, in terms of those core components, Enterprise is comprised of a web server for access,
an Enterprise server, which is going to handle all the business logic behind the scenes. And then we'll
have one or more scanning machines, which are the entities that actually perform the scans. Think of
these as your automated penetration testers effectively. All of those components will connect
to some form of SQL database, and there's a few different options there. And then, naturally,
we've got our users or API clients accessing that through the web server.
Alex O' In terms of deployment options, we've got the standard installation method, which is
basically choosing your OS of choice. That's Windows, various flavors of Linux, or Mac OS. And then you
would run our installer on top of that. And effectively, as long as it's 64-bit and can run Java 11,
you're probably going to be good to go from a deployment perspective. And then that standard
installation process can either be single machine or multi-system, which we'll cover off in a second.
And then second option is the Kubernetes deployment, which is quite a new release for us.
So, if you've got more of a preference around containerization, then this is the choice for you.
So, this is deployed via a provided Helm chart. And again, that works with any x86-based cluster.
There are some prerequisites to meet, but the idea is kind of irrespective of your infrastructure. As long
as you meet those, you should be able to run them on a cluster of your choice.
This also gives us the advantage of auto-scaling scanning machines. So, whereas with the standard
installer, we pre-provision those scanning machines, i.e. we create the resource, be it a VM or physical
machine, and then kind of sit there either scanning or not scanning. With Kubernetes, we can take advantage
of that cluster architecture. And actually, we don't pre-provision the scanning machines. They are
created when a scan job is created. The scan job will run, and then when it finishes, the scanning
machine will be killed off. And naturally, that has a net benefit in terms of cost for a cloud
environment. It effectively pays you use. So, for the standard installer single machine deployment,
as the name sounds, all of those components that we discussed are deployed to a single physical or
virtual machine. This is great for a trial or evaluation purpose. Nice and easy to get up and running.
All the components live together, and you're scanning pretty much straight away. And you can see some of
the connectivity that is required there. So, for example, out to portswigger.net, that's for the
license activation and automated updates. Users will access the web server over the default port of 8080,
but that can be changed and secured if required. Burp collaborator is also used for those pro users.
It works in the same way. And these are effectively for sort of out-of-bound and payload type attacks.
And then naturally, you need to be able to target those websites that you want to scan,
either HTTP or S. Multi-system is where the notion of scale comes in with BurpSuite Enterprise. So,
the idea that we can be running dozens, hundreds, thousands of scans at the same time. So, we start
to separate those components out. So, the web server and enterprise server will still live together.
You might still use our bundled H2 database. Most customers would choose their own external
database. And again, we've got a list, a document that details what those can be.
And also, the scanning machine will be deployed externally. You can deploy as many of these as you
like and distribute your concurrent scan limit from a license perspective as you kind of see fit. And
again, there's some best practice around how many scans per scanning machine relative to CPU and RAM.
That's all documented on our website. Connectivity-wise, it's all the same. We're still talking to the same
components. But again, because we can deploy as many scanning machines as we wish, we can support a
large environment from a scanning perspective. If you want to go down the Kubernetes route, you need
to meet these three prerequisites. So, we used to provide options for CloudFormation and ARM templates,
but those are fairly restrictive in terms of the infrastructure. So, now you just need some sort of
ingress solutions. That's typically going to be a load balancer or ingress controller. You'll need a
persistent volume claim. So, that'll be application name that you give it, dash pvc. And that needs to
be shared by all the nodes in the namespace. And then to enable the cluster autoscaling, autoscaler
must be installed and enabled as well. So, with these prerequisites met, you'll be able to deploy to
AWS GCP, private cluster, etc. So, in terms of what that looks like, there's kind of a split of the
responsibilities, i.e. what we give you in terms of the Helm chart and then what you would need to
provide. So, for Mr. or Mrs. Customer, ingress, web service, and the database. And we still do have
documentation around deploying the database and the scripts, etc. It's just that that's external to the
to the Helm chart as such. And then for the Helm chart, web server pod, enterprise service,
enterprise server pod will be deployed. And then the scanner pod is effectively managed by the
enterprise server itself. We do have a reference template available for AWS. If you don't necessarily
want to deploy or have your own cluster, I'm going to bring those out for Azure and GCP and other
platforms as we move forward. So, we've put everything together that we've learned around
the architecture and the licensing. This is what a typical purchase and deployment would look like.
So, you've bought Burps 3 Enterprise license with 15 concurrent scans because you've determined from the
trial that's a suitable number from a currency perspective. Concurrency perspective, sorry. Decided that
you want to deploy to AWS EC2 using the standard installation process multi-machine. So, we deploy
an image with the enterprise and web server and the same for an external database, Postgres in this case.
And then we need to decide how we want to distribute those concurrent scans. So, along the lines of best
practice, we're going to deploy three scanning machines, each enabled with five concurrent scans,
giving us our 15 in total. And that's a good spread from a resource perspective as well,
particularly around performance. So, perhaps throughout that 12-month subscription in this example,
our applications might scale up in terms of our portfolio. We might need to run more scans.
So, that concurrency can scale with you too. So, at any point you can add additional scan concurrency.
In this case, we've deployed another scanning machine and assigned an additional five concurrent scans to it.
So, from a purchase perspective, that initial purchase with the 15 will be US$11,985 across a one-year subscription.
And then at some point we've added those five, which is going to be 2495, that'll be pro-rotted
against the subscription as well. All nice and straightforward.
So, with the architecture and deployment options out of the way, we'll jump to the demo and just give you a
sort of look and feel and some of the changes that have been made around the interface. So, straight away,
our first task is probably going to be to set up our team. So, we do have role-based access control.
Enterprise, in contrast to Pro is very much designed to be team-based. So, we have roles that we can
create with a set of permissions, i.e. what we want that particular user to be able to do. We've got some
pre-built roles here, but you have complete control to create a role as you see fit. So, if I go to new
role, we can see here, we've got a list of permissions for effectively everything you can
do within the UI. And then you can assign those roles to groups and add your users into groups for
easier management. Now, those are local users. So, if we jump into integrations, we'll also see that
we do support SAML and LDAP. So, if you'd rather pass across an existing group of users, either AD or
from your identity provider, that's supported as well. And if you just want those to be managed in terms
of authentication, but have more direct management over the groups, we've got a SCIM module for that.
Once our team is set up, we'll probably want to check out our scanning machines. So, we can see
this deployment is a single machine deployment with a local scanning machine. We can see our local IP
here. But I could deploy as many external scanning machines as I wish and link those back to this
installation. And we'll see our license limit down here. So, this is a trial. And with the trial,
you get 35 concurrent scans with which to test with. And then you'll see these toggle buttons.
I can distribute those 35 amongst the scanning machines as I see fit. So, it's kind of where I
need those resources to be. I can define those into scanning pools. That's potentially a collection
of scanning machines tied to particular sites. So, from again, a resource allocation perspective,
that can be quite useful. And then as I allocate scans, that concurrency will be filled up until it
becomes busy. And then scans would queue if I kept assigning scans. Maybe I would increase that limit
if need be under certain scenarios. But essentially, once a scan finishes and it is freed up, like
you'd scan would then kick off. So, we've got our team set up. Our scanning machines are good to go.
And the premise of scanning is very straightforward. So, we want to create sites or target applications.
And then we're going to scan schedule on top of those sites. So, all the configuration is done at site
level. And the scans are effectively just our schedule. So, as a new deployment, maybe we've
got lots of sites with which we want to import. So, we have a CSV template designed to just do exactly
that. So, we can populate all our sites in one go. But very quickly, if I show you what it looks like
to create a new site. So, we'll give it a name. We can distribute that into folders. So, we can see
earlier, we've got this carved out. Could be team, could be geographical location, however you see fit.
And then we need to complete our site scope. So, this is going to be the highest level URL
that we want to include as part of the scan. And then we can use the inclusive and exclusive rules
to define that even further. By default, that's always going to be HTTP and S, or I can specify
one of those specific protocols. And then it comes to configuring the scan itself, which again is taken
from that site configuration. And a very recent addition that we've had are these preset scan modes,
designed to get you up and running as quick as possible. We've got some different choices there.
So, for example, you might have a daily lightweight scan that you just run every single day, because
it's designed to run over 15 minutes. And it just gives me a quick sort of insight into how that
application is doing. And then perhaps I'll have another schedule whereby I run a more thorough scan.
So, perhaps the deep one, which has enhanced coverage in terms of the crawl and audit,
and maybe I'll run that on a weekly basis to get a deeper insight into those vulnerabilities or issues.
I still have complete control over that configuration as well. So, maybe I've created a custom one,
or I want to use one of the pre-built scan configurations. So, if we use a drop-down list here,
we can start to control things around the crawl, audit, maybe want to minimize false positives.
So, any custom scan configurations you add will be added to this library as well.
If our scan is requiring authentication, we can add that here as well. So, very basic login credentials,
username, password, anything more complex than that, and we would use our recorded login sequence.
This is a plugin in the browser, and it records you logging into the application. So, anything along the
lines of multi-page SSO authentication, that's more suitable to recorded login sequence. And we can
cut and paste the JSON that is generated from that process, and the crawler will use that every time
it wants to log into the application. We can also add extensions, as Sophie mentioned earlier. So,
again, this might be changing the behavior of a configuration. We could be adding something in,
and then we can assign our scan pool as well. So, once we've created that site, we would then want to
start our scans. So, you can see here we've got a whole bunch of scans that have been running on our
schedule basis previously. So, if I go to new scan, you can run one ad hoc. So, I select my site,
that's going to run as soon as possible, run it once. But ideally, I want to be creating my schedules
because I want to build out that sort of picture over time or a security posture for my application,
and the schedule is the best way to do that. Again, I can create different schedules daily, weekly,
monthly, yearly, and match scan configurations to those types of activities. I can schedule for a date and
time and then repeat it. I could do that forever, repeat a set number of times or until a particular date.
And then I would just save that schedule, or it would run straight away if I had an ad hoc site on the go.
So, if I jump into an older scan that's been run, this is what the dashboard looks like from a scan
results perspective. And I can start to analyze those results. So, we get a list of issues. So, that's carved out into
other severity rating and confidence. So, high, medium, low, and informational, and then certain firm,
tentative, or perhaps a false positive that we've marked. But we can start to drill down into this
detail and I'll select a location where the vulnerability has been found, and I'll be presented
with the advisory. So, issue detail, background information, remediation steps specific to that
vulnerability. There'll always be some kind of reference to our web security academy, which pro users
might be familiar with, and a sandbox environment where I can carry out that particular payload.
And the classifications for that particular vulnerability as well. I can view the request,
and the response. And if upon further investigation, I determine that actually this might be a false
positive, I can mark it as such. I've got some sort of global rules around that, how I kind of carry it
forward. So, maybe I just mark this one particular issue. But if I'm going to run further scans, and I
don't want it to be picked up again, I can do it for the site or the site of the URL.
If I go back to my results, we can look at reporting and logs as well. So, I can generate a HTML report
with either a summary or detailed report, which is great for other lines of business that might want to
investigate or report on the issues that have been found for an application scan. And we've quite
recently added some compliance reporting as well. So, our initial edition is OWASP top 10 and PCI DSS. So,
that's going to classify the scan results into those particular sets of compliance reports. And our plan
is to expand this in the future as well. So, that's kind of the scan 101. Again, the idea around
importing all of our sites and creating that schedule. And then we can get that sort of longer term view.
So, if I look at one of the sites that have been running, again, we start to build that picture over
time. So, security posture, what issues have been resolved, have any regressed, and start to map that out.
And then I might want to start building out integrations for my installation as well. So,
if I go into integrations here, we can do things like issue tracking. So, Jira, GitLab, and Trello have
been added so far, both for manual and automatic ticket creation. So, where we marked that false positive
earlier, if this was configured, we'd also have the option to raise a Jira ticket, for example. Or perhaps
it's automatically going to do it based on the severity and confidence level of any issues that have been
found. Slack can also be configured from a notification perspective in terms of scans in
progress, scans finishing. And then quite a large use case for enterprise are the pipeline scans.
So, we've got an example here of Jenkins. So, we have specific plugins for both Jenkins and Team
City. But then there's also the generic driver, which effectively works with anything as long as you can
run the JAR file. Typically, that's going to work with other platforms such as Azure DevOps, Bitbucket,
etc. But the notion is that we're giving that awareness to Jenkins to insert a scan into our
pipeline. And we know what issues are being found so that we can fail the build if we need to. So,
if I jump into configure, what the plugin or the driver is giving us is some very specific build
steps related to scans. So, Burp site-driven scan and Burp scan are our two options. Site-driven scan
being our typical recommendation, because we're pulling all of that site configuration data at the
site level. So, there's very little actually to do in terms of the pipeline scan. But if, for example,
you didn't know where the application was being deployed to for a particular pipeline,
and you needed to be a bit more dynamic in terms of the URL, we could use the Burp scan and just
echo that out as we do it. We connect to our enterprise server via the URL and GraphQL API
key. And then we populate our site list from that integration so we can select which site we want to
scan as part of that pipeline, select when we want the build to fail. So, again, on that severity or
confidence level. Perhaps we actually want to permit a certain number of issues if we've got a threshold
we want to kind of meet. And as a developer, if I'm controlling this process, I can actually generate
a report from this pipeline scan as well and choose where that's going to be stored. But naturally,
you also have access to the GraphQL API and all of the mutations that are available so I can interact
with enterprise in any way I kind of see fit as a developer. Okay, folks, that's the demo from a kind of
101 perspective. If you need more detail, I would absolutely encourage you to reach out or even
perhaps go for the trial itself. And we've got some cool new features coming out that we'll discuss in
a sec. Tso? So I'm going to talk a little bit about our roadmap. So we make our roadmap public.
So it's available directly from our site. And it just gives you a bit of an idea in terms of what a dev
team is currently working on, and new features and functionality that you can expect to see in 2022.
So we did promise you a sneak peek of the roadmap and some new features that have just been released,
and some upcoming features that are due to be released. So back over to Alex for a sneak peek.
Okay, so we already mentioned the preset scan configuration modes that have come out very recently,
and these have been received very well. So I'd absolutely encourage you to give these
a go. We've got a target application that we developed ourselves designed to kind of reflect
a modern web application. So very quickly in terms of getting set up, you're about to use that as a
as a test case as well. We're also introducing this concept of the timeline for scans. So it's all sort
of well and good, you know, creating that schedule, kicking off scans, looking at results.
Sometimes you'll probably want to know the progress of scans as well. So that's the concept of the
of the timeline, the timeline giving you that sort of feedback. So you split everything up into the
stages that the scan will go through, and it's going to give you feedback in terms of what's going on.
So you can see here, we've just kicked off the scan. So it's queued waiting to be assigned to an
available scanning machine. The scan will start, then we'll enter the crawl phase, and we'll start to
see things like the requests being made, unique locations, and the current URL it's up to. Same goes for
auditing when we hit the audit phase, we're going to start to see those issues being generated, and
again, which URL we're currently looking at. And we'll also get feedback in terms of any notifications
or errors that we might need to address will be fed back here as well. And then we know when the scan
is finished, we can take a look at those results.
Cool. So that brings us to the Q&A. So thank you to everyone who's popped the questions into the Q&A
box. So I'm just going to have a quick read and pick out a couple to answer now. As I said previously,
if we don't answer your question on the session today, don't worry, we're going to be sending out
an email later this week with the answer to all the questions that were asked anyway. Just to kick us
off then, someone has asked, we use Azure DevOps for our CI CD pipeline, does Enterprise integrate with this?
So yeah, as you mentioned, we've got the generic driver or platform agnostic driver,
which you'll be able to utilize with Azure DevOps as a batch script effectively. So if you take a look
at the documentation on our website for the generic driver, it'll give you an example of a script you
can use along with some optional parameters that you can build out with that command. But again,
feel free to reach out to us if you need any assistance with that.
Thanks, Alex. The next one, can I get another trial to test the new features as it's been a while
since my last trial? The answer, absolutely. We will be reaching out via an email the next couple of days.
So if you're a person that would like a new free 30-day trial of Enterprise, please just reply to the
email, let us know and we'll get you set up with a new trial licence.
So the professional extensions are typically built specifically with professional in mind in terms
of the UI and that won't translate to work with Enterprise because naturally the UIs are completely
different. Additionally, currently Enterprise extensions are only written in Java. That's what
it supports. And quite often you'll find the professional extensions written in Python or a
combination of the two. So again, they're not automatically going to be compatible. Most of our
BAPs are community based and we do publish the framework for making your own. So if there's anything
you see that is available in Pro and doesn't currently work in Enterprise, you can reach out to us
or even have a go at making your own as well. Thanks, Alex. Just want to be sure I'll not be
limited to the number of applications I can scan or the number of users. So that's absolutely right.
There's no limit on users, URLs, domains. The only limit is on scan concurrency and that's dictated by
the number of concurrent scans that you purchase. This is unlike most automated web vulnerability scanners
that with Burpsuit Enterprise Edition the scans can be assigned and reassigned across any number of
websites, applications and URLs. And just to finish this off, does the concurrent scan limit apply to the
same application which gets triggered parallelly by different developers in the CI CD pipeline?
Alex Blanche- Okay, yes. I mean, there's no limit on the number of developers that could interact
either via the API or via a pipeline. But any scans created will count towards that concurrency limit.
So you'll definitely want to factor in when you're trying to determine how many sort of concurrent scans
you might need. So just to kind of give a bit more flavour to that, if we come back to our Jenkins
deployment here, if I build this with that scan step added, what it's effectively doing is initiating an
API based scan back to my Enterprise install. So if I come back and go to scans, we'll see here that a
scan has been kicked off. Go back to my scanning machine, you can see now one's been assigned. So
it does count towards that concurrency. So something to factor in. And probably one thing just to mention
around the whole sort of pipeline notion is that we are actually looking to move away from the driver.
So we do get a lot of questions, you know, does your driver support XYZ in terms of the platform?
But we're moving towards containerisation. So that question is almost a moot point or will be a
moot point because as a container, it's going to work with anything.
So as I mentioned before, any of your questions that haven't been answered via the chat or live today,
we will be sending out an email to make sure that everybody's questions do get an answer. And so just
watch out for that email. If you've got any further questions, feel free just to reply to that email
and obviously, let us know. So in terms of what happens next, as I just said, responses sent via email,
and the Portswagon hour will be available on YouTube shortly. If you want to forward it to any of your
colleagues or anybody else that it would be of interest to, please feel free to do so. For those
that asked if you would like another trial, just get in contact, reach out. And if you're currently
trialling, you do have access to support, but if you're unsure how to use it or you do have any
additional questions, please feel free just to reach out and reply to our email. And finally, if you're an
existing customer and you would, you require you've scaled up a little bit since you purchased your
license and you would like some more concurrent scans, please feel free to reach out or reply to
our email and let us know. So that's all for today's Swiginar. Thank you so much to everybody that has
joined and hopefully we'll speak to you soon. Thanks all. Thanks. Bye.
Bye.
!